absolutely fantastic to be here in berry
to launch our local election campaign
right here in the sunshine this morning
and that means
that we've got five weeks exactly five
weeks
to send a message to boris johnson's
tories that they can't ignore
a message that britain deserves better
than their pathetic
their miserable response to the cost of
living crisis so it's fantastic to be
here to start that campaign and to start
it with all of you
you know the reality
price is through the roof
wages through the floor
inflation higher than it's been since
well last time the tories were in power
and what's
their response what's their response
with the cost of living standards of
living the lowest
since the 1950s
tax the highest for 70 years what's
their response to this
is to take more than they give to take
more so on average families this year 2
620 pounds worse off
under these tourists that is the cost of
the tories
and it's so frustrating
because britain has so much to be proud
of
but we don't have a government
that's on the side of working people
that's on the side of businesses that's
on the side of pensioners
and that's the difference with labour
labour is a party
that is on your side
that takes your worries and your
concerns seriously and has a plan
a plan for a better
future a better britain a practical plan
that we can put into action
my contract with the british people the
contract i want to have on behalf of the
labour party a labour government with
the british people
is about the security that we need
the prosperity
that we want
and the respect that everybody deserves
security is important people at the
moment feel they can't pay their bills
they're worried
tossing and turning at night about what
they can make ends meet so we need the
security of knowing you can pay your
bills that's why
we had the windfall tax a practical way
to tax the oil and gas companies who
made profits they didn't expect to make
and say use that money
so that people can have up to 600 pounds
off their bills that's what security
looks like the security of knowing that
you're safe in your job
the scandal of piano would not have
happened under a labour government a
scandal
it would not have happened under our
look angela rainer has drawn up that
green paper a better deal for working
people and that's what gives them people
that security at work
and of course security at home and in
our communities too many people fear
anti-social behavior fair crime feel
they can't go out of their doors after
dark
because they haven't got a government
that's on their side
we need prosperity people want their
ambitions and aspirations to be
cherished and valued to have the skills
they need to go on in their lives to do
what they want to do
to have their businesses supported their
local economies thriving that's the
prosperity that we need
and then of course
respect
probably the most important
clause in my contract respect deep
respect for people
whoever they are
but wherever they come from
we need change this is time for change
we need to get britain back on track
i'm beyond proud and privileged to be
leader of the labour party
but i don't want to be leader of the
opposition
i want labour in power
labor in power changing lives
and that's what this election is about
the chance to have labor councillors on
your side changing lives aaron o'brien
here
with barry making a real difference
waking up every morning thinking how can
i make things better for the families
the communities that i represent that's
the difference that labor makes in power
that's the difference
of a labour party that's on your side
fighting anti-social behavior protecting
public services
actually having that ambition for a
better britain excited about what we can
do
together so our message is very very
clear vote labor on the fifth of may to
send a message to the tories about their
labour on the 5th responses may because
britain deserves better
vote labor on the 5th of may
for a party that is on your side
thank you so much